[Music]
how was your easter do you have a good
time yeah it was good i mean uh you know
the kids of course they got up early uh
probably actually before the sun even
came up and uh you know we told them go
back to bed for a while and then
uh they finally did get up you know like
about seven and we went out and we
hunted for the eggs and they found some
candy and stuff and uh it's hard to keep
them from eating too much candy
you know and we had a like a nice brunch
plan too so it was it was hard to keep
him from
what what what are you doing
what what what no i'm not here
i'm listening to your story
no you weren't you were fading away i
was not i was
the second someone else gets some
attention you just start to fade right
now that's not fair that is not true it
is absolutely true i mean i know that
your name is on the show but i've got
things to contribute to i mean i can
tell stories and i can tell jokes i mean
i'm not a great singer but i'm an okay
singer i can do impressions ever
you're doing it again okay wait a minute
okay wait no seriously i
i really i i swear i'm paying attention
i am i i i am
you've got an ego problem and i i'm not
the only one who's noticed it i mean a
lot of people around you have known
steve our stage manager he notices jeff
our executive producer mike sweeney our
head writer he's we talk about it all
the time lighting directors
okay
see i'm going to prove it to you
it's got to be about you watch this
uh man conan's a great talk show host
isn't he huh
yeah it's just funny
so quick on his feet such a good rapport
with the guests yeah and especially man
you really get on with the lead i do
see all right okay thank you for
pointing that out andy i i never
realized how much i need other people's
attention and yeah but you're you andy
are a big part of the show i appreciate
your contributions the amazing energy
you bring to your job i want you to know
that
when behalf is successful without you
wait a minute here i see now you're
fading out yeah i do that when i smell
[ __ ]
well anyway we've got a terrible show
tonight oh do we ever
but thank you